hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're going
to be looking at a cool little trap
called the fishing pole and it derives
from the roy lopez opening as many y'all
know the royal apes' opening is one of
the most common up things that you'll
see so if you do play a lot chess
especially playing as black probably
going to have a lot of opportunities to
try this out on your opponents and also
what I like about the trap is even if it
doesn't work as you'll see we're going
to go over a lot of different variations
today you're not going to have a bad
game you're still going to have a lot of
good opportunities to equalize and
there's also a lot of traps that you can
find within the fishing pole that even
if your opponent doesn't fall for the
first trap you can employ some further
traps later on to see if he can hang
himself so we'll go ahead and get into
it roy lopez starts with pawn to b4 we
respond pani five white develops his
knight we continue 9c six white brings
his Bishop to b5 attacking our knight
we're going to bring our knight to f6
and why it's going to Castle now a lot
of beginners just thought I'd touch on
this we'll say you know why would why
would White Castle here why wouldn't he
bring his Knight to c3 defending his
pawn
well technically his pawn is defended
after Knight to e4 capturing then the
rook can come to e1 and they're going to
get their material back so a lot of
times you'll see especially a higher
level play you'll see white simply just
castle and that's what we're going to
look at today if white castles on this
move from here black and simply do the
move Knight to g4 now this move looks
kind of funny at first but we're going
to get into how it's actually very very
dangerous for white one of white's
biggest things that he's going to want
to do is try to get this knight out of
there obviously the Knights putting a
lot of pressure on h2 on f2 and there's
nothing he can do about it right now so
one of the most common things you'll see
is simply pawn to h3 obviously trying to
kick this night away seems like a good
idea from here though we're simply going
to reinforce this knight and give
up as a sacrifice and hopefully why
we'll hang himself by doing this if
someone has not seen this trap before
more than likely they will go ahead and
take this piece that you've given to him
when we recapture what we've done is two
things one we've unleashed our rook on
this h-file just bearing down there's
nowhere for the king to go right now and
we're also attacking this knight if Y
decides to move his knight it's actually
going to be game over for white black is
going to win right away as you can see
let's say white tries to retreat his
knight to e1 obviously right now white
is up in material but from here we can
bring our Queen to h4 and black has won
the game there's nowhere for the King to
go we can come to h2 h1 on our next few
moves if he tries to bring his pawn out
let's say on the F file to give his King
room to move we can simply on our next
move just bring our pawn to g3 and now
there's absolutely nothing the white
King can do if he tries to move his rook
to give him room against if we come to
h1 if not we can simply come to h2 it's
going to be checkmate so if he does move
his Knight just know it's going to be
checkmate so obviously you may not
always see him take his knight so we'll
go ahead and take a look at a lot of
different variations if he doesn't take
his Knight and then we'll look at what
happens if he doesn't even move his pawn
at all so from here if we bring our
Knight to g4 and he comes to h3 and we
reinforce with pawn to h5 you may not
see him take he may think hey wait a
minute this could be a trap he may have
seen the fishing pole and say hey this
is a trap so you may see a few moves one
of the moves you may see is simply
someone who's very confused they just
want to go ahead and start taking
material they know that you probably
have something up your sleeve they may
just go ahead and take on c6 this is the
exchange variation in the Royal open so
a lot of players are familiar with it so
they may go ahead and continue along
their strategy right now there's nothing
too much that black can do so they're
going to continue on from here we can
capture on
see six and then from here same thing if
he wants to take we can continue along
with our plans but you may see something
like pawn to d4 obviously they're trying
to counter in the center from here we
can recapture if he recaptures with his
queen we can recapture with our queen if
he does recapture with his knight we can
just simply retreat our knight obviously
now our attack is no longer working but
you can already see where even in
material and our development is
completely fun we can develop our our
light square bishop we can Castle
queenside which is very common in the
exchange barrier printing the royal
exchange variation in the royal lopez
there's nothing bad about our game here
and that's why was going over earlier
even if the trap doesn't work and he
doesn't fall for it like still going to
have a very good game which is something
you definitely want to keep in mind so
we'll go back a few moves and let's say
he doesn't capture on c6 let's say he
develops his Knight to c3 very common
move you may see from here we can simply
bring our knight to d4 threatening this
knight here again basically putting a
lot of pressure on white from here he
may capture we can recapture attacking
his knight if he wants to content
obviously you can't bring his knight to
let's say d5 because then we can just
move pawn to c6 attacking both pieces
let's say he brings it back to e -
we can simply start attacking the bishop
if he moves his bishop back to a4 then
we can set up another little trap here
basically giving up our d4 pawn to his
knight so what we can do is we can
simply bring our knight back to e5
basically sacrificing our pawn on d4 but
if he does take on d4 we can simply
attack and then when he moves we can
simply take if he does recapture with
his queen which he probably will if he
captures with his pawn his King side's
going to be wide open then we can simply
start attacking his bishop and his
bishops going to be trapped now he could
try and move like pawn to e5 attacking
our rook here but as soon as we move it
his bishops still going to be on the run
and as soon as he moves boom we've
trapped his Bishop here so just a small
little thing that you can continue to
apply pressure and even if they don't
fall for the trap you can still have a
decisive advantage so we've taken a look
we'll go back a few moves here taking a
look at what happens if he develops his
knight to c6 but what if he doesn't even
move his pawn to h3 we'll go back a few
moves he doesn't have to move his pawn
to h3 he may simply he could bring his
Knight to c3 now from here we can bring
our Bishop to d6 obviously eventually we
yes we are blocking off our LightSquared
bishop but more than like we're going to
bring in a light square Bishop to a6 or
b7 and get it involved later on but
right now we're defending our pawn on e5
in developing our bishop so that we can
Castle kingside
from here you may see him bring his pawn
to h3 or you may see him simply bring
let's say bring his pawn to d3 if he
doesn't even want to worry about h3 even
later on from here we can simply Castle
kingside he can develop his Bishop as
you can see we
always bring her knight back to f6 if we
want suit we have a completely fine game
our development is fine the trap didn't
work but that's not a problem that's one
of the key things you need to know about
this is even if the trap doesn't work
you're still going to have a fine game
so hope you guys enjoyed this video if
you haven't already please subscribe and
I'll see you guys thanks video thanks
for watching everybody